okay I have a question for all of us you
ready is all winning success oh oh okay
I am the recently retired head coach of
the UCLA women's gymnastics team a
position that I held for 29 years thank
you and and during my tenure I
experienced a lot of winning I let our
team of seven national championships I
was inducted into the UCLA I thought of
Hall of Fame and I was even voted the
coach of the century by the pac-12
contracts winning is really really like
really really fun but I am here to share
my insight winning does not always equal
success all across America and around
the world we have a crisis in the win at
all cost cultures that we have created
in our schools and our businesses and
politics winning at all cost has become
acceptable as a society we honor the
people at the top of the pyramid we
effusive ly applaud those people who win
championships and elections and awards
but sadly quite often those same people
are leaving their institutions as
damaged human beings sadly with straight
A's kids are leaving school damaged with
awards and medals athletes often leave
their teams damaged emotionally mentally
not just physically and with huge
profits employees often leave their
companies damaged we have become so
hyper focused on that
and result and when the end result is a
win the human component of how we got
there often gets swept under the
proverbial rug and so does the damage so
I'm calling for a timeout timeout we
need to redefine success real success is
developing champions in life for our
world
win or lose real successes of developing
champions and life's not for your team
not for your business and I'm sad to
tell you not even for your Christmas
card bragging rights sorry so how do we
do this first of all you may be able to
dictate your way to a win but you can't
dictate your way to success let me take
you back to 1990 when I was first
appointed the head coach of the UCLA
women's gymnastics team and I would like
to share with you that I've never done
gymnastics I grew up in the world of
ballet I have never done a cartwheel and
I couldn't teach you how to do a proper
cartwheel it's sadly true and I knew
nothing about how to develop a team
culture the best I could do was mimic
other coaches who had won and so I
became tough talking tough minded
relentless unsympathetic bullish an
empathetic and oftentimes downright mean
I acted like a head coach whose only
thought was to figure out how to win my
first few seasons as a head coach were
abysmal and after putting up with my
brash coaching style for a few years our
team asked me for a team meeting well I
loved him eating so I said yay let's
have a team meeting and for two solid
hours
they gave me examples of how my
arrogance was hurtful and demeaning yeah
not yay they explained to me that they
wanted to be supported not belittled
they want to be coached up not torn down
they wanted to be motivated not
pressured or bullied that was my time
out and I chose to change being a dog
maduk dictator may produce compliant
good little soldiers but it doesn't
develop champions in life it is so much
easier in any walk of life to dictate
and give orders than to actually figure
out how to motivate someone to want to
be better and the reason is we all know
this motivation takes a really long time
to take root but when it does it is
character building and life altering I
realized that I needed to fortify our
student-athletes as whole human beings
not just athletes who won so success
from me shifted from only focusing on
winning to developing my coaching
philosophy which is developing champions
in life through sport and I knew if I
did this well enough that champion
mentality would translate to the
competition floor and it did the key
ingredient was to develop trust through
patience respectful honesty and
accountability all of the ingredients
that go into tough love speaking of
tough love Kaitlyn Ohashi is a perfect
example of this you may have all seen
her floor routine it has had over a
hundred and fifty million views and the
consensus is her performance is pure joy
however when Kaitlyn
to UCLA she was broken in body mind and
spirit she had grown up in a
stereotypical very high-level athletic
world and she was damaged so when
Caitlyn came to UCLA her freshman year
she found her inner rebel quite well to
the point where she was no longer able
to do gymnastics at the level at which
she was recruited and I will never
forget a team meeting we had halfway
through her freshman season we were in
there with the team the coaching staff
the support staff sports psychologists
and Caitlyn very clearly and
unapologetically said I just don't want
to be great again I felt like I got
sucker-punched my first thought was then
why the heck am I going to honor your
scholarship it was a really snarky
thought and thankfully I didn't say it
out loud because then I had clarity
Caitlyn didn't hate gymnastics Caitlyn
hated everything associated with being
great Caitlyn didn't want to be a winner
because wing at all cost had cost her
her joy my job was to figure out how to
motivate her to want to be great again
by helping her redefine success
my enthusiasm for that challenge turned
a determination when one day Caitlyn
looked me in the eye and said Miss foul
I just want you to know everything you
tell me to do I do the exact opposite
yeah it's like yet Kaling challenge
accepted okay and further proof that
dictating was not going to win so I
embarked on the painfully slow process
of building trust and proving to her
that first and foremost I cared about
her as a whole human being part of my
strategy was to only talk to Kaitlyn
about gymnastics in the gym outside of
the gym we talked about everything else
schoolboys families friends hobbies I
encouraged her to find things outside of
her sport that brought her joy and it
was so cool to see the process of Kaelyn
Ohashi
literally blossom before our eyes and
through that process she rediscovered
her self love and self worth and slowly
she was able to bring that joy back to
her gymnastics she went on to earn the
NCAA title on floor and she helped our
team win our seventh NCAA championship
in 2018 so thank you so let's think
about the Kaitlyn ohhohh shoes in your
life let's think about those people
under your care and your guidance what
are you telling your kids on the car
ride home that car ride home has much
more impact than you know are you
focusing on the end result or are you
excited to use that time to help your
child develop into a champion it's very
simple you will know you're focusing on
the end result if you ask questions
about the end result
did you win how many points did you
score did you get an A if you truly are
motivated about helping your child
develop them into a champion you will
ask questions at
about the experience and the process
like what did you learn today
did you help a teammate and my favorite
question did you figure out how to have
fun at working really really hard and
then the key is to be very still and
listen to their response I believe that
one of the greatest gifts we can give
another human being
it's a silence our minds from the need
to be right or they need to formulate
the appropriate response and truly
listen when someone else is talking and
in silencing our minds we actually hear
our own fears and inadequacies which can
help us formulate our response with more
clarity and empathy Kyla Ross another
one of our gymnasts is one of the
greatest gymnasts in the history of the
sport
she's the only athlete to have earned
the trifecta she's a national champion a
world champion and an Olympic champion
she's also not one for small talk
so I was a bit surprised one day when
she came to my office sat on the couch
and just started talking first about her
major then about graduate school and
then about everything else that seemed
to pop into her mind my inner voice
whispered to me that something was on
her mind and if I was still and gave her
enough time it would come out and it did
it was the first time that Kyla had
shared with anyone that she had been
sexually abused by Larry Nasser
the former USA gymnastics team doctor
who was later convicted of being a
serial child molester
Kyla came forward and joined the army of
Nasr survivors who shared their stories
and used their voices
to invoke positive change for our world
I felt it was extremely important at
that time to provide a safe space for
Kyla and our team and so I chose to talk
about this in a few team meetings later
that year we won the national
championship and after we did Kyla came
up to me and shared with me the fact
that she felt one reason that we'd won
was because we had addressed the
elephant in the room the tragedy that it
not only rocked the world but that had
liberated the truths and the memories in
herself and in so many of her friends
and her peers as Kyla said miss Val I
literally felt myself walk taller as the
season went on and when I walked on to
that championship floor I felt
invincible simply
[Applause]
simply because she had been heard as
parents as coaches as leaders we can no
longer lead from a place where winning
is our only metric of success where our
ego sits center stage because it has
been proven that that process produces
broken human beings and I emphatically
know that it is absolutely possible to
produce it and train champions in life
in every same goal walk of life without
compromising the human spirit
[Music]
it starts with defining success for
yourself and those under your care and
then consistently self examining whether
your actions are in alignment with your
goals we are all coaches in some
capacity we all have a collective
responsibility to develop champions in
life for our world that is what real
success looks like and in the world of
athletics that is what we call a win-win
thank you
[Applause]